hi I'm Ryan and um Zach and we're here
with a monday morning review with a side
of spoilers for neighbors starring Zac
Efron and Seth Rogen shirtless Zac Efron
shirtless Zac Efron and shirtless Seth
Rogen let's just get down to the
nitty-gritty here this is a really funny
movie really funny it's funny throughout
and like in this day and age there's
something to be said for that it has
comic momentum um and all of the all of
the chokeslam yeah um the one the one
criticism I'd have which isn't even
really a criticism is that if the movie
is just all jokes it's not there's no
like up and down it's just kind of like
here's the premise there frats next door
we need to get rid of them it is
probably the funniest movie i've seen
this year that's a lot the funniest
live-action movie I've seen this year
yeah so I mean the gags just build on
each other and we've seen we've seen a
lot of them the trailers huh but we are
in the theater you really do get that
refreshing moment real like oh like I'm
gonna pretend like I haven't seen this
yeah I bagged a good example is the air
bag thing I had seen that yeah because
you know we see the trailers a ton of
time obviously a lot of people in the
theater didn't know was coming and it
landed really a rose byrne is brilliant
yeah her chemistry Seth Rogen is yeah
she's just awesome and and having been a
fan of hers in dramatic work for a long
time it's kind of cool to see with this
and bridesmaid um how funny she is and
Zac Efron as per usual really delivers
yeah you know I was surprised because I
haven't I've seen him in stuff but I
haven't really paid attention to his
acting and I thought he's just gonna
play the guy that
I'm gonna hate throughout the movie feel
really badly for him yeah he's kind of
he kind of plays just like a dim-witted
guy who I can't grow up a little bit um
and I think that he's really turning
into a really really great comic
performer in the audience I was with was
eating it up all the way through and
there's a lot of layer jokes that it
seems like upon repeated viewings it'll
hold up really well um and there's also
of note just a few very like bit parts
from jerod Carmichael who's really
really funny christmas plots um is very
funny and he's kind of doing is like
usual thing um and Hannibal Buress as
the cop Bowl God whose willers so every
scene these are you hey world yeah but
yeah let us know what you thought
comment below and please remember to buy
your tickets of Fandango by clicking
right here until next time I'm Ryan and
I'm Zack thank you for watching